the internet has changed everything that
we do
it's become as much of a part of our
everyday lives as eating and drinking
it's revolutionized the way that we
interact with people at home and around
the world
enabling Millions to take their work
with them on the go wherever they are
change the way that we shop the way that
we consume our entertainment and most
recently the way that we spend money
in fact it's even paved the way for a
new type of money to spend which is
called cryptocurrency
so what is cryptocurrency
how is it affecting our lives and who
are the major players
it's time to uncover the facts behind it
one of the internet's largest companies
Facebook and their bid to revolutionize
cryptocurrency itself
by now you've undoubtedly heard of one
of the most popular forms of
cryptocurrency available today Bitcoin
Bitcoin is a decentralized digital
currency without a central bank or
single administrator that can be sent
from user to user on the peer-to-peer
Bitcoin Network without the need for
intermediaries
transactions are verified by Network
nodes through cryptography and recorded
in a public distributed Ledger called a
blockchain
Bitcoin was invented by an unknown
person or group of people using the name
Satoshi Nakamoto
and was released as open source software
in 2009
Bitcoins are created as a reward for a
process known as mining
they can be exchanged for other
currencies products and services
research produced by University of
Cambridge estimates that in 2017 there
were 2.9 to 5.8 million unique users
using a cryptocurrency wallet most of
them using Bitcoin
Bitcoin has been criticized for its use
in illegal transactions its high
electricity consumption price volatility
thefts from exchanges and by reputable
economists stating that it should have a
zero price
Bitcoin has also been used as an
investment although over the years
several Regulatory Agencies have issued
investor alerts about Bitcoin
let's go back to where and when it all
began
the domain name bitcoin.org was
registered on the 18th of August 2008.
on the 31st of October 2008 a link to a
paper authored by Satoshi Nakamoto
titled Bitcoin a peer-to-peer electronic
cash system was posted to a cryptography
mailing list
Nakamoto implemented the Bitcoin
software as open source code and
released it in January 2009
nakamoto's identity remains unknown
on January the 3rd 2009 the Bitcoin
network was created when Nakamoto mined
the first block of the chain known as
The Genesis block
embedded in the coinbase of this block
was the text
the times the 3rd of January 2009
Chancellor on brink of second bailout
for banks
this note references a headline
published by the times and has been
interpreted as both a timestamp and a
comment on the instability caused by
fractional reverse banking
the receiver of the first Bitcoin
transaction was cyberpunk Hal Finney who
created the first reusable proof-of-work
system also known as rpow in 2004
Finney downloaded the Bitcoin software
on its release date and on January the
12 2009 received 10 Bitcoins from
Nakamoto
other early cyberpunk supporters were
creator of Bitcoin predecessors guaydai
creator of b-money and Nick zaboy
creator of Bitcoin
in 2010 the first known commercial
transaction using Bitcoin occurred when
programmer Laszlo Hanes bought two Papa
John's Pizzas for 10 000 Bitcoin
blockchain analysts estimate that
Nakamoto had mined about 1 million
Bitcoins before disappearing in 2010
when he handed the network alert key and
control of the code repository over to
Gavin Andresen
Anderson later became lead developer at
the Bitcoin Foundation
Anderson then sought to decentralize
control
this left opportunity for controversy to
develop over the future development path
of Bitcoin in contrast to the perceived
authority of nakamoto's contributions
after early proof of concept
transactions the first major uses of
Bitcoin were black markets such as Silk
Road
during its 30 months of existence
beginning in February 2011 Silk Road
exclusively accepted Bitcoins as payment
transacting 9.9 million in bitcoins
worth about 214 million dollars
in 2011 the price started at 0.3 dollars
per Bitcoin growing to 5.27 for the year
the price Rose to 31.50 on June the 8th
of that same year
within a month the price fell to eleven
dollars
the next month it fell to 7.80 and in
another month to 4.77
in 2012 Bitcoin prices started at 5.27
growing to 13.30 for the year
by the 9th of January the price had
risen to 7.38 but then crashed by 49 to
3.80 over the next 16 days
the price then Rose to
16.41 on the 17th of August but fell by
57 to 7.10 over the next three days
the Bitcoin Foundation was founded in
September 2012 to promote bitcoin's
development and uptake
in 2013 prices started at 13.30 rising
to 770 by the first of January 2014.
in March 2013 the blockchain temporarily
split into two independent chains with
different rules due to a bug in version
0.8 of the Bitcoin software
the two blockchains operated
simultaneously for six hours each with
its own version of the transaction
history from the moment of the split
normal operation was restored when the
majority of the network downgraded to
version 0.7 of the Bitcoin software
selecting the Backward Compatible
version of the blockchain
as a result this blockchain became the
longest chain and could be accepted by
all participants regardless of their
Bitcoin software version
during the split the mount gox exchange
briefly halted Bitcoin deposits and the
price dropped by 23 to 37 before
recovering to previous level of
approximately 48 in the following hours
the U.S financial crimes enforcement
Network fincen established regulatory
guidelines for decentralized virtual
currencies such as Bitcoin classifying
American Bitcoin miners who sell their
generated Bitcoins as money service
businesses msbs that are subject to
registration or other legal obligations
in April exchanges bit instant and mount
gox experienced processing delays due to
insufficient capacity resulting in the
Bitcoin price dropping from 266 dollars
to seventy six dollars before returning
to 160 within six hours
the Bitcoin price Rose to 259 on the
10th of April but then crashed by 83 to
45 over the next three days
on the 15th of May 2013 U.S authorities
seized accounts associated with Mount
gox after discovering it had not
registered as a money transmitter with
Finn sen in the U.S
on June 23 2013 the U.S Drug Enforcement
Administration listed 11.02 Bitcoin as a
seized asset in a United States
Department of Justice seizure notice
pursuant to 21 USC
881
[Music]
this marked the first time a government
agency had seized Bitcoin
the FBI seized about 30 000 Bitcoin in
October 2013 from the dark website Silk
Road during the arrest of Ross William
ulbricht these Bitcoins were sold at
blind auction by the United States
Marshals service to venture capital
investor Tim Draper
bitcoin's price Rose to 755 on the 19th
of November and crashed by 50 to 378
dollars the same day
on the 30th November 2013 the price
reached
1163 before starting a long-term crash
declining by 87 to 152 in January 2015.
on December the 5th 2013 The People's
Bank of China prohibited Chinese
financial institutions from using
Bitcoins
after the announcement the value of
Bitcoins dropped and Baidu no longer
accepted Bitcoins for certain services
buying real world Goods with any virtual
currency had been illegal in China since
at least 2009.
in 2014 prices started at 770 and fell
to 314 for the year
on July the 30th 2014 the Wikimedia
Foundation started accepting donations
of Bitcoin
in 2015 prices started at 314 and Rose
to 434 dollars for the year
in 2016 Prices rose to 998 on January
the 1st 2017.
prices started at 998 dollars in 2017
and Rose to 13
412.44 on the 1st of January 2018 after
reaching its all-time high of
19783.06 on December the 17th 2017.
China ban trading in Bitcoin with first
steps taken in September 2017 and a
complete ban that started on February
the 1st 2018.
[Music]
Bitcoin prices then fell from 9052
dollars
to
6914 on the 5th of February 2018.
the percentage of Bitcoin trading in the
Chinese Ren mendai fell from over 90 in
September 2017 to less than one percent
in June 2018.
throughout the rest of the first half of
2018
bitcoin's price fluctuated between 11
480 and
5848 dollars
on the 1st of July 2018 bitcoin's price
was six thousand three hundred and forty
three dollars
the price on January the 1st 2019 was
3747 down 72 percent for 2018
and down 81 since the all-time high
Bitcoin prices were negatively affected
by several hacks or thefts from
cryptocurrency exchanges including
thefts from coin check in January 2018.
coin Rail and bit Thumb in June and
bangkor in July
for the first six months of 2018
761 million dollars worth of
cryptocurrencies were reported stolen
from exchanges
bitcoin's price was affected even though
other cryptocurrencies were stolen at
coin Rail and bancor as investors
worried about the security of
cryptocurrency exchanges
Bitcoin transactions are defined using a
fourth-like scripting language
when a user sends Bitcoins the user
designates each address and the amount
of Bitcoin being sent to that address in
an output
to prevent double spending each input
must refer to a previous unspent output
in the blockchain
the use of multiple inputs corresponds
to the use of multiple coins in a cash
transaction
since transactions can have multiple
outputs users can send Bitcoins to
multiple recipients in one transaction
as in a cash transaction the sum of
inputs coins used to pay can exceed the
intended sum of payments
in such a case an additional output is
used returning the change back to the
payer
any input satoshis not accounted for in
the transaction outputs becomes the
transaction fee
though transaction fees are optional
miners can choose which transactions to
process and prioritize those that pay
higher fees
miners may choose transactions based on
the fee paid relative to their storage
size not the absolute amount of money
paid as a fee
these fees are generally measured in
satoshis per byte
the size of transactions is dependent on
the number of inputs used to create the
transaction and the number of outputs
throughout the years Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies have made quite the
impact on society and the crypto craze
continues to gain online and in-use
momentum it was only a matter of time
before other internet Giants stood up to
take notice even one of the biggest of
them all Facebook
Facebook Incorporated is an American
online social media and social
networking service company based in
Menlo Park California
it was founded by Mark Zuckerberg along
with fellow Harvard college students and
roommates Eduardo Saverin Andrew
McCollum Dustin Moskowitz and Chris
Hughes
it is considered one of the big four
technology companies along with Amazon
Apple and Google
Founders initially limited the website's
membership to Harvard students and
subsequently Columbia Stanford and Yale
students
membership was eventually expanded to
the remaining Ivy League schools mitt
and higher educational institutions in
the Boston area then various other
universities and lastly high school
students since 2006 anyone who claims to
be at least 13 years old has been
allowed to become a registered user of
Facebook
though this may vary depending on local
laws
the name comes from the Facebook
directories often given to American
University students Facebook held its
initial public offering IPO in February
2012 valuing the company at 104 billion
dollars the largest valuation to date
for a newly listed public company
Facebook makes most of its revenue from
advertisements that appear on screen and
in users news feeds
the Facebook service can be accessed
from devices with internet connectivity
such as personal computers tablets and
smartphones
after registering users can create a
customized profile revealing information
about themselves
they can post text photos and multimedia
which is shared with any other users
that have agreed to be their friend
users can also use various embedded apps
join common interest groups and receive
notifications of their friends
activities
Facebook claimed that it had more than
2.3 billion monthly active users as of
December 2018. however it faces a big
problem of fake accounts it caught three
billion fake accounts but the ones it
misses are the real problem
many critics questioned whether Facebook
knows how many actual users it has
Facebook is one of the world's most
valuable companies
it receives prominent media coverage
including many controversies
these often involve user privacy as with
the Cambridge analytica data scandal
political manipulation
as with the 2016 U.S elections
psychological effects such as addiction
and low self-esteem and content that
some users find objectionable including
fake news conspiracy theories and
copyright infringement
Facebook also does not remove false
information from its Pages which brings
continuous controversies
the commentators stated that Facebook
helps to spread false information and
fake news
Facebook offers other products and
services it acquired Instagram WhatsApp
Oculus and grog Style
and independently developed Facebook
messenger Facebook watch and Facebook
portal
Zuckerberg originally built a website
called facemash in 2003 while attending
Harvard University
the site was comparable to hot or not
and used photos compiled from the online
Facebooks of nine houses placing two
next to each other at a time and asking
users to choose the hotter person
facemash attracted 450 visitors and 22
000 photo views in its first four hours
the site was sent to several campus
group list servers but was shut down a
few days later by Harvard Administration
Zuckerberg faced expulsion and was
charged with breaching security
violating copyrights and violating
individual privacy
ultimately the charges were dropped
Zuckerberg expanded on this project that
semester by creating a social study tool
ahead of an art history final exam
he uploaded all art images to a website
Each of which was accompanied by a
comments section then shared the site
with his classmates
a Facebook is a student directory
featuring photos and personal
information
in 2003 Harvard had only a paper version
along with private online directories
Zuckerberg told the crimson
everyone's been talking a lot about a
universal Facebook within Harvard
I think it's kind of silly that it would
take the university a couple of years to
get around to it
I can do it better than they can and I
can do it in a week
in January 2004 Zuckerberg coded a new
website known as the Facebook inspired
by a crimson editorial about facemash
stating it is clear that the technology
needed to create a centralized website
is readily available the benefits are
many
Zuckerberg met with Harvard student
Eduardo savarin and each of them agreed
to invest one thousand dollars in the
site
on February the 4th 2004 Zuckerberg
launched the Facebook originally located
at thefacebook.com
six days after the site launched Harvard
seniors Cameron Winklevoss Tyler
Winklevoss and Divya Narendra accused
Zuckerberg of intentionally misleading
them into believing that he would help
them build a social network called
harvardconnection.com
they claimed that he was instead using
their ideas to build a competing product
the three complained to the crimson and
the newspaper began an investigation
they later sued Zuckerberg settling in
2008 for 1.2 million shares
worth 300 million dollars at Facebook's
IPO
membership was initially restricted to
students of Harvard College
within months more than half the
undergraduates had registered
Dustin Moskowitz Andrew McCollum and
Chris Hughes joined Zuckerberg to help
manage the growth of the website
in March 2004 Facebook expanded to
Colombia Stanford and Yale and then to
all Ivy League colleges
Boston University New York University
mitt
and successively most universities in
the United States and Canada
in mid-2004 Napster co-founder and
entrepreneur Sean Parker an informal
advisor to Zuckerberg became company
president
in June 2004 the company moved to Palo
Alto California it received its first
investment later that month from PayPal
co-founder Peter Thiel
in 2005 the company dropped the from its
name
after purchasing the domain name
facebook.com
for two hundred thousand US dollars
the domain had belonged to about face
Corporation
in May 2005
for partners invested 12.7 million
dollars in Facebook and Jim Breyer added
1 million dollars of his own money
a high school version of the site
launched in September 2005.
eligibility expanded to include
employees of several companies including
Apple Inc
and Microsoft
on September 26 2006 Facebook opened to
everyone at least 13 years old with a
valid email address
by late 2007 Facebook had 100
000 pages on which companies promoted
themselves
organization Pages began rolling out in
May 2009
on October 24 2007
Microsoft announced that it had
purchased a 1.6 share of Facebook for
240 million dollars giving Facebook a
total implied value of around 15 billion
dollars
Microsoft's purchase included rights to
place international advertisements
in October 2008 Facebook announced that
its International headquarters would
locate in Dublin Ireland
in September 2009 Facebook said that it
had achieved positive cash flow for the
first time
a January 2009 compete.com study ranked
Facebook the most used social networking
service by Nationwide monthly active
users
the company announced 500 million users
in July 2010.
half of the site's membership used
Facebook daily for an average of 34
minutes
while 150 million users accessed the
site from mobile devices
a company representative called the
Milestone a quiet Revolution
in November 2010 based on second Market
Inc and exchange for privately held
companies shares Facebook's value was 41
billion dollars
the company had slightly surpassed eBay
to become the third largest American Web
company after Google and amazon.com
on November the 15th 2010 Facebook
announced it had acquired the domain
name fb.com from the American Farm
Bureau Federation for an undisclosed
amount
on January the 11th 2011 the Farm Bureau
disclosed 8.5 million dollars in domain
sales income
making the acquisition of fb.com one of
the 10 highest domain sales in history
in February 2011 Facebook announced
plans to move its headquarters to the
former Sun Microsystems campus in Menlo
Park California
in March 2011 it was reported that
Facebook was removing about 20 000
profiles daily for violations such as
spam graphic content and underage use as
part of its efforts to boost cyber
security
statistics show that Facebook reached 1
trillion page views in the month of June
2011 making it the most visited website
tracked by double click
according to a Nielsen study Facebook
had in 2011 become the second most
accessed website in the US behind Google
in March 2012 Facebook announced App
Center a store selling applications that
operate via the website
the store was to be available on iPhones
Android devices and mobile web users
in April 2012 Facebook acquired
Instagram for approximately 1 billion in
cash and stock
Facebook's initial public offering came
on May the 17th 2012 at a share price of
38 dollars
the company was valued at 104 billion
dollars the largest valuation to that
date
the IPO raised 16 billion dollars the
third largest in U.S history after Visa
Inc in 2008 and a T and T Wireless in
2000.
based on its 2012 income of 5 billion
Facebook joined the Fortune 500 list for
the first time in May 2013 ranked 462.
the shares set a first day record for
trading volume of an IPO 46 million
shares the IPO was controversial given
the immediate price declines that
followed and was the subject of lawsuits
while SEC and finra both launched
investigations
Zuckerberg announced at the start of
October 2012 that Facebook had one
billion monthly active users including
600 million mobile users
219 billion photo uploads and 140
billion friend connections on April 12
2016 Zuckerberg outlined his 10-year
Vision which rested on three main
pillars artificial intelligence
increased Global connectivity and
virtual augmented reality
in June Facebook announced deep text a
natural language processing AI
that learns user intent and context in
20 languages
things were going well for Zuckerberg
and his company but as is always the
case it wasn't long before people began
using this amazing technology to further
their own agendas
controversy was just around the corner
on September the 28 2018 Facebook
experienced a major breach of its
security exposing the data of 50 million
users the data breach started in July
2017 and was discovered on September the
16th
Facebook notified users affected by the
exploit and log them out of their
accounts
in March 2019 Facebook confirmed a
password compromise of millions of
Facebook Lite application users however
in April the company further stated that
it was not just limited to Facebook but
it also affected millions of Instagram
users
the reason cited was the storage of
password as plain text instead of
encryption which could be read by its
employees
Facebook apologies have appeared in
newspapers television blog posts and on
Facebook
on March 25th 2018 leading U.S and UK
newspapers published full-page ads with
a personal apology from Zuckerberg
Zuckerberg issued a verbal apology on
CNN in May 2010 he apologized for
discrepancies in privacy settings
hideously Facebook had its privacy
settings spread over 20 pages and has
now put all of its privacy settings on
one page which makes it harder for
third-party apps to access the user's
personal information
in addition to publicly apologizing
Facebook has said that it will be
reviewing and auditing thousands of apps
that display suspicious activities in an
effort to ensure that this breach of
privacy does not happen again
in a 2010 report regarding privacy a
research project stated that not a lot
of information is available regarding
the consequences of what people disclose
online
so often what is available are just
reports made available through popular
media
in 2017 a former Facebook executive went
on record to discuss how social media
platforms have contributed to the
unraveling of the fabric of society
Facebook relies on its users to generate
the content that bonds its users to the
service the company has come under
criticism both for allowing
objectionable content including
conspiracy theories and Fringe discourse
and for prohibiting other content that
it deems inappropriate
it has been criticized a vector for fake
news and has been accused of bearing
responsibility for the conspiracy theory
that the United States created Isis
false anti-rahingya posts being used by
myanmar's military to fuel genocide and
ethnic cleansing enabling Sandy Hook
Elementary School shooting conspiracy
theorists and anti-refugee attacks in
Germany
the government of the Philippines has
also used Facebook as a tool to attack
its critics
Facebook has repeatedly amended its
content policies in July 2018 it stated
that it would downrank articles that its
fact Checkers determined to be false and
remove misinformation that incited
violence
Zuckerberg once stated that it was
unclear whether Holocaust deniers on
Facebook intended to deceive others for
which he later apologized
Facebook stated that content that
receives false ratings from its fact
checkers can be demonetized and suffered
dramatically reduced distribution
specific posts and videos that violate
Community standards can be removed on
Facebook
in May 2019 Facebook banned a number of
dangerous commentators from its platform
including Alex Jones Louis Farren Khan
Milo yanapoulos Paul Joseph Watson Paul
Nealon David Duke and Laura Luma
for allegedly engaging in violence and
hate
in 2018 special counsel Robert Mueller
indicted 13 Russian Nationals and three
Russian organizations for engaging in
operations to interfere with U.S
political and electoral processes
including the 2016 presidential election
Mueller contacted Facebook subsequently
to the company's disclosure that it had
sold more than one hundred thousand
dollars worth of ads to a company
internet research agency with links to
the Russian intelligence Community
before the 2016 U.S presidential
election
in September 2017 Facebook's Chief
security officer Alex Stamos wrote the
company
found approximately one hundred thousand
dollars in ad spending from June of 2015
to May of 2017 associated with roughly 3
000 ads that was connected to about 470
inauthentic accounts and pages in
violation of our policies
our analysis suggests these accounts and
Pages were affiliated with one another
and likely operated out of Russia
Clinton and Trump campaigns spent 81
million on Facebook ads
the company pledged full cooperation in
the Mueller investigation and provided
all information about the Russian
advertisements including the identities
of the individuals and companies who
made the purchases members of the House
and Senate intelligence committees have
claimed that Facebook had withheld
information that could illuminate the
Russian propaganda campaign
Russian operatives have used Facebook to
organize black lives matter rallies and
anti-immigration rallies on U.S soil as
well as anti-clinton rallies and rallies
both for and against Donald Trump
Facebook ads have also been used to
exploit divisions over black political
activism and Muslims by simultaneously
sending contrary messages to different
users based on their political and
demographic characteristics in order to
so Discord
in some cases real people have been
impersonated to these ends
Zuckerberg has stated that he regrets
having dismissed concerns over Russia
interference in the 2016 U.S
presidential election
in January 2019
Facebook removed 289 pages and 75
coordinated accounts linked to the
Russian state-owned news agency Sputnik
which had misrepresented themselves as
independent news or general interest
pages
in total these accounts had around 790
000 followers and had spent around 135
000 on Advertising between October 2013
and January 2019
Facebook later identified and removed an
additional
1907 accounts linked to Russia found to
be engaging in coordinated inauthentic
Behavior
in 2018 the UK dcms select committee's
report had criticized Facebook for its
reluctance to investigate abuse of its
platform by the Russian government and
for downplaying the extent of the
problem
none of these incidents have ended up
defining this Juggernaut of a company
and their future has never seemed
brighter
over the years Facebook and Zuckerberg
have been the subject of music books
film and television
the 2010 film The Social Network
directed by David Fincher and written by
Aeron Sorkin stars Jesse Eisenberg a
Zuckerberg and went on to win three
Academy Awards and four Golden Globes
in 2008 Collins English dictionary
declared Facebook as its new word of the
year
in December 2009 the New Oxford American
Dictionary declared its word of the year
to be the verb unfriend
defined as to remove someone as a friend
on a social networking site such as
Facebook
in August 2013 Facebook founded
internet.org in collaboration with six
other technology companies to plan and
help build affordable internet access
for underdeveloped and developing
countries
its goal was to bring internet access
and the benefits of connectivity to the
portion of the world that doesn't have
them
the service called free Basics includes
various low bandwidth applications such
as AccuWeather baby center BBC News ESPN
and the search engine Bing
by 2018 Mark Zuckerberg said our
internet.org efforts have helped almost
100 million people get access to the
internet who may not have had it
otherwise
free Basics is available in dozens of
countries
with their legacy cemented and Horizons
bright Facebook made the bid to enter
the world of cryptocurrency
in May of 2019 Facebook founded Libra
networks reportedly in order to develop
their own stablecoin cryptocurrency
in recent developments it has been
reported that Libra is being supported
by Financial companies like Visa
Mastercard PayPal and Uber
the Consortium of companies is expected
to pool in 10 million dollars each to
fund the launch of the cryptocurrency
coin named Libra
Libra is a permissioned blockchain
digital currency proposed by the
American social media company
the project currency and transactions
are to be managed and cryptographically
entrusted to the Libra Association a
membership organization founded by
Facebook subsidiary caliber and 27
others across payment technology
telecommunication Online Marketplace
venture capital and non-profits
as of July 2019 the currency and network
do not yet exist and only rudimentary
experimental code has been released the
launch is planned to be in 2020
Facebook vice president David a Marcus
moved from Facebook Messenger to a new
blockchain division in May 2018.
first reports of Facebook planning a
cryptocurrency with Marcus in charge
emerged a few days later
by February 2019 there were more than 50
Engineers working on the project
confirmation that Facebook intended a
cryptocurrency first emerged in May
2019.
at this time it was known as Global coin
or Facebook coin
on July the 15th 2019 Facebook announced
the currency will not launch until all
regulatory concerns have been met and
the appropriate approvals
the plan is for the Libra token to be
backed by Financial assets such as a
basket of currencies and U.S treasury
Securities in an attempt to avoid
volatility
Facebook has announced that each of the
partners will inject an initial 10
million dollars so Libra has full asset
backing on the day it opens
Libra Service Partners within the Libra
Association will create new Libra
currency units based on demand
Libra currency units will be retired as
they are redeemed for conventional
currency
initial reconciliation of transactions
will be performed at each service
partner
and the blockchain's distributed Ledger
will be used for reconciliation between
Service Partners
the intent is to help prevent everyone
but members of the Libra Association
from trying to extract and analyze data
from the distributed Ledger
in contrast to cryptocurrencies such as
Bitcoin which use permissionless
blockchains Libra is not decentralized
relying on trust in the Libra
Association as a de facto Central Bank
Facebook had previously established the
Libra Association to oversee the
currency founded by 28 members in Geneva
Switzerland
the project has faced criticism and
opposition from central banks the use of
a cryptocurrency and blockchain for the
implementation has been questioned
U.S regulators and politicians expressed
concerns close on the mid-2019
announcement
Maxine Waters chairperson of the United
States House committee on Financial
Services committee asked Facebook to
Halt the development and launch of Libra
citing a list of recent scandals that
the cryptocurrency market currently
lacks a clear regulatory framework
the U.S House committee on Financial
Services Democrats sent a letter to
Facebook asking the company to stop
development of Libra citing concerns of
privacy National Security trading and
monetary policy
Jerome Powell chair of the Federal
Reserve testified before Congress on the
10th of July that the FED had serious
concerns as to how Libra would deal with
money laundering consumer protection and
financial stability
president Donald Trump tweeted on the
12th of July that if Facebook and other
companies want to become a bank they
must seek a new banking Charter and
become subject to all banking
regulations
French Finance Minister Bruno Lemaire
told French radio station Europe won
that Libra could not be allowed to
become a sovereign currency
he warned French parliament of his
concerns about Libra and privacy money
laundering and terrorism Finance
he called on the Central Bank governors
of the group of seven to prepare a
report on Facebook's plans
Bank of England Governor Mike Carney
said there was a need to keep an open
mind about new technology for money
transfers but anything that works in
this world will become instantly
systemic and will have to be subject to
the highest standards of Regulation
German MEP Marcus Ferber warned that
Facebook could become a shadow Bank
the government of Japan has begun the
process of investigating Libra and doing
an analysis on the effect of Japan's
monetary policy and financial regulation
this will be done before the Group of
Seven meeting in France between the 24th
and the 26th of August 2019.
the Swiss Federal data protection and
information commissioner that Davis
Marcus told the U.S Senate would oversee
privacy for Libra said that it had not
heard from Facebook at all
industry observers have speculated
whether Libra will provide meaningful
privacy to its users
Facebook's plan is to let its subsidiary
caliber manage Libra for Facebook users
and Facebook Executives have stated that
caliber will not Share account holders
purchase information with Facebook
without authorization
however the system is also planned to
include a friend finder search function
and the use of this function will
constitute permission for caliber to
combine the account holders transaction
history with their Facebook account
Libra will not rely on cryptocurrency
mining
only members of the Libra Association
will be able to process transactions via
the permissioned blockchain
Libra hopes to begin transitioning to a
permissionless proof of stake system
within five years although their own
materials admit that no solution exists
that can deliver the scale stability and
security needed to support billions of
people and transactions across the globe
through a permissionless network
Libra's source code is written in Rust
and published as open source under the
Apache license with the launch on the
18th of June 2019.
ileu an opinion writer at Bloomberg News
tried compiling and running the publicly
released code for Libra
as supplied the software did little more
than allow fake coins to be put in a
wallet almost all of the white paper
functionality is not implemented
including major architectural features
that have yet to be invented who was
surprised that Facebook would release
software in such a state
Facebook plans to release a digital
wallet called caliber in 2020
made available in messenger WhatsApp as
well as in a standalone app
move is the Libra blockchain's proposed
smart contract and custom transactions
language
compiled to bytecode
how this all plays out remains to be
seen
but given the success of
cryptocurrencies and the strong
networking Communications of the social
media giant the pairing is poised for
success as long as the public at large
keeps clicking that ever so prominent
like button